je sais je sais ça vous avez manqué vous
étiez au 400 coups et ben écoutez soyez
content ça y est c'est aujourd'hui le
quatrième épisode de dt6 Simon alors si
vous connaissez pas le concept c'est
hyper simple je vais faire un tour sur
les forums santé vous connaissez
sûrement je choisis les questions les
plus
les plus étonnantes où les plus
intéressantes ou les deux et j'y réponds
ici enfin quand c'est possible bien sûr
mais de toute façon on en parle et on en
sort toujours quelque chose
d'intéressant et de bon à savoir allez
on perd pas plus de temps c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il y a pas de thématiques
particulières comme il y en avait dans
les derniers épisodes on va prendre ce
qui vient on commence avec un truc
tranquille et puis après on ira
crescendo le chêne d'eau c'est de
l'italien ça veut dire qui augmente
petit à petit qui prend de l'ampleur qui
grandit comme bonjour
depuis quatre mois je commence à avoir
marre de ça combien ça dure merci
d'avance voilà j'avais promis on
commence tranquille où alors non c'est
pas une faute de frappe une fistule
anale avec élastique ça existe alors
qu'est-ce que c'est à votre avis déjà
c'est quoi une fistule vous savez
peut-être pas une fistule c'est deux
cavités qui devraient pas se rejoindre
et qui communique entre elles quand même
c'est un petit tunnel entre deux
endroits qui n'étaient pas destinés à se
rencontrer si vous voulez une espèce de
passage secret quoi qui reste pas secret
longtemps en général par exemple si on a
une fistule qui relie nos intestins à
notre vessie on peut s'en rendre compte
parce qu'on se met à des prouts je vous
jure que c'est vrai ça s'appelle une
pneumaturie et si on vomit du caca ça
peut être le signe qu'on a une fistule
gastro colique c'est-à-dire entre
l'estomac et le côlon il y a aussi des
fistules artériaux veineuses donc entre
des veines et des artères etc etc et là
on parle de fistule anale c'est-à-dire
un petit tunnel entre le canal anal et
le monde extérieur alors vous allez me
dire bah le canal anal et le monde
extérieur ça communique aussi en temps
normal oui mais pas par là et du coup là
ça peut s'infecter et ça peut même créer
un abcès voilà donc ça c'est une fistule
soit on est avec soit ça apparaît plus
tard pour différentes raisons mais une
fistule avec élastique à votre avis
qu'est-ce que c'est non c'est pas une
fistule qui fait des sports extrêmes
c'est une fistule qui a été soignée
soigner une fistule ça veut dire la
nettoyer évacuer tout ce qui arrive le
pus en gros pour éviter que ça se
referme comme ça par dessus du coup que
ça se réinfecte que ça refasse un abcès
et que ça recommence et quand je dis
nettoyer il faut savoir que le
chirurgien il nettoie essentiellement à
coup de bistouri et donc le chirurgien
il peut décider de laisser un fil
élastique tout le long de la fistule à
l'intérieur pour éviter que ça se
referme tant que toutes les saloperies
n'ont pas été évacuées et donc laisser
un fil ça peut aussi éviter d'avoir à
les mettre un coup de bistouri si la
fistule touche le sphincter parce que là
il y aurait un risque d'incontinence
d'un continent fécale et donc ce fil il
est élastique parce que comme ça on peut
le resserrer au fur et à mesure que ça
se vide enfin le chirurgien en fait pas
ça chez vous voilà et si vous voulez
tout savoir cet élastique en fait ça
s'appelle un Setton c'est pas de la
bouffe vegan c'est pas un petit
personnage provençal qu'on met dans la
crèche c'est un petit élastique qu'on
met dans et normalement on le laisse en
place maximum 12 semaines c'est à dire
trois mois avant de réopérer donc là
effectivement pour notre ami ça fait 4
mois je comprends qu'il trouve le temps
un petit peu long je suis sûr aurores à
votre avis c'est quoi je
vois pas de quoi on parle on va cliquer
pour voir
[Musique]
oui bien sûr ah ça au début ça surprend
bon moi maintenant je suis habitué mais
je comprends que vous bienvenue dans mes
DM bon pour répondre quand même à la
question à votre avis c'est quoi à mon
avis c'est un trou en gros plan alors je
suis en train de me dire il y a
peut-être une thématique à cet épisode
finalement bonjour à tous je voulais
savoir si comme moi des personnes sont
hypocondriaques je suis nature anxieuse
et je dois passer des examens médicaux
je m'imagine le pire qu'un cancer etc si
vous avez des solutions pour m'aider à
combattre ce mal-être je suis preneur
merci
une thématique alors déjà attention
c'est pas parce qu'on s'inquiète pour sa
santé qu'on est hypocondriaque et
s'imaginer le pire quand on a un truc un
peu inhabituel ou même pas d'ailleurs
c'est hyper répandu en fait ça tient à
plusieurs choses d'abord le fait qu'on
déteste ne pas savoir et ne pas
comprendre ça ça nous pousse à imaginer
des réponses au lieu d'attendre juste la
réponse ensuite cette tendance globale
qu'on a nos autres les êtres humains à
toujours envisager le pire scénario
quand on cherche
justement donnez moi par exemple il y a
quelques jours j'ai eu la main gonflée
je vous cache pas que quand j'ai entendu
parler d'arthrite septique j'étais pas
serein spoiler manifestement je m'étais
juste cogné le médecin m'a donné de la
pommade en deux jours c'était réglé et
puis il y a l'accès qu'on a aux
informations sur notre santé et là il se
passe de trucs déjà on a tout et tous
autour de nous des potes pour venir nous
dire la tête et mon grand-père a eu ça
c'était une méningite ça l'a emporté en
48 heures et puis il y a tout ce qu'on
peut trouver sur internet sur le site de
santé ou sur les forums de santé par
exemple pour un symptôme lambda tu as
toujours une liste de maladies
incroyable qui va du simple rhume
jusqu'au cancer et pour les raisons dont
je vais parler avant quand on sait que
ce qu'on a ça peut être un signe de
cancer et ben on pense plus qu'à ça même
si statistiquement il y a très très peu
de chances que ce soit ça tout ça c'est
humain mais il y a aussi des trucs plus
embêtant comme le syndrome de l'étudiant
en médecine par exemple en gros c'est
quand quelqu'un qui fait médecine
s'autodiagnostic ou diagnostic aux
autres genre ses proches les maladies
qui louaient en train d'étudier en cours
ça c'est un vrai trouble de santé avec
des conséquences pour soi-même et pour
les autres comme l'hypocondrie on estime
que 3,5% des gens sont hypocondriaques
donc il faut faire la différence entre
un truc très répandu s'inquiéter dès
qu'on a en fait travers et une maladie
mentale avec des vrais grosses
conséquences sur la vie quotidienne mais
vu que la question de base c'était
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire je vous donne
quelques éléments de réponse d'abord si
c'est vraiment envahissant consulter un
ou une professionnelle mais c'est un psy
etc et puis si vous avez tendance à être
inquiet la première chose à faire c'est
de ne pas chercher à avoir de réponse
avant d'avoir la vraie réponse je sais
c'est facile à dire mais commencez par
se répéter je serai fixé bientôt les
gens dont c'est le métier s'en occupe
c'est un bon début puis en attendant
d'avoir la vraie réponse il faut se
rappeler que un seul signe ne fait pas
une maladie par exemple oui la toux on
la retrouve dans les Rumes et dans
certains cancers mais dans le cas du
cancer c'est si la toux elle est
persistante genre plus de deux semaines
et s'il y a plusieurs autres signes
associés que c'est conseillé d'aller
consulter et même dans ces cas-là c'est
pas forcément des signes qui sont pas
spécifique donc bon ça peut aussi être
d'autres trucs évidemment c'est
compliqué surtout si on est de nature
anxieuse mais voilà l'idée c'est de
faire fonctionner son cerveau rationnel
pour endormir un peu son cerveau
émotionnel et puis en parler aussi ça
fait toujours du bien bonjour homme de
37 ans j'ai été diagnostiquée
d'hémorroïdes internes il y a quelques
jours par un médecin spécialiste mais
symptôme sont surtout le saignement
depuis une dizaine de jours qui survient
uniquement après les selles et qui est
souvent sous la forme de la coloration
rosée du papier avec lequel je me suis
je viens de commencer le traitement il y
a deux jours je remarque lorsque mes
selles sont volumineuses je n'ai pas de
saignement mais lorsque j'ai des petites
selles en volume il y en a
systématiquement comment pourrait-on
expliquer ceci merci pour vos réponses
ok donc c'est reparti alors déjà des
hémorroïdes tout le monde en a j'en ai
vous en avez tout le monde en a même
Beyoncé à des hémorroïdes
parce que les hémorroïdes c'est le nom
des veines qu'on a dans là où ça pose
problème c'est quand ces hémorroïdes
donc c'est veine elle reste gonflées en
permanence là ça s'appelle la maladie
hémorroïdaire et j'en ai déjà parlé dans
une vidéo donc retourner la regarder si
vous voulez comprendre comment ça marche
et donc vous avez bien entendu notre ami
parle d'hémorroïdes internes parce que
oui il y a des hémorroïdes internes et
des hémorroïdes externes mais non je
l'ai déjà dit il y a pas d'hémorroïdes
demi-pensionnaire par contre bref un des
problèmes avec les hémorroïdes en plus
de la douleur c'est qu'elles peuvent
saigner si elles sont irritées par un
truc là la question c'est est-ce que des
selles volumineuses donc des gros caca
pour dire les choses clairement ça fait
moins saigner que des petits cacas dans
l'absolu non enfin j'ai jamais entendu
dire ça et je me suis renseigné j'ai
rien trouvé là-dessus d'ailleurs on voit
pas bien pourquoi des gros caca ça
ferait moins saigner que des petits caca
le seul truc que je vois c'est si ça se
trouve quand cette personne fait des
petits cacas c'est peut-être qu'elle est
constipée du coup le problème c'est pas
que les crottes sont toutes petites
c'est qu'elles sont dures et que du coup
elles abîment les hémorroïdes en passant
et en plus quand on est constipé faut
pousser plus fort ça ça fait monter la
pression et ça c'est pas bon non plus
pour les mêmes alors que quand elle a
des selles volumineuses c'est peut-être
juste que paf ça passe comme ça tout
seul du coup ça fait pas de bobos sur
son passage c'est pas tant un problème
de volume que de consistance en fait
d'ailleurs après une opération des
hémorroïdes on conseille de boire plein
d'eau et de bien manger des fibres pour
faire des jolis petits cacas tout doux
voilà voilà bonjour depuis un mois
maintenant j'ai des douleurs au
bas-ventre sensation de brûlure de
pesanteur je sens mon cœur qui pulse à
cet endroit envie de faire pipi pour me
soulager selon voilà test d'infection
urinaire négative test de grossesse
négatif prise de sang pour vérifier le
taux de globules blancs normal et
échographie pelvienne normale pas de
kyste ou autre mon médecin ayant fait le
tour ne me propose rien d'autre or j'ai
de plus en plus mal ça me donne des
grandes difficultés pour dormir
avez-vous une idée j'envisage même
d'aller voir un guérisseur merci
d'avance donc on sait pas déplacé très
loin mais on change quand même un petit
peu de registre déjà je répète à chaque
fois mais je ne fais pas de diagnostic
d'abord parce que je suis pas médecin
ensuite parce que même les médecins ils
font pas des diagnostics comme ça mais
on peut quand même émettre des
hypothèses la manifestement c'est pas un
truc évident c'est pas un truc courant
qu'on peut détecter avec les examens
habituels je vais pas passer en revue
toutes les possibilités mais juste pour
vous en donner une peut-être que ça va
si et hypersensible
oui ça existe vraiment c'est une
atteinte des capteurs de la douleur au
niveau de la vessie ça peut aussi être
une vessie hyperactive
c'est une vessie qui se contracte sans
raison comme ça par moment il y a plein
de possibilités parmi des trucs qui sont
pas les plus courants après aller voir
un guérisseur vous faites comme vous
voulez mais bon à mon avis c'est mieux
de persévérer et de continuer à chercher
le vrai problème là en l'occurrence vu
que le médecin trouve rien peut-être qui
part du principe que c'est dans la tête
alors on a déjà parlé des douleurs
psychogènes ici ça vient de la tête
peut-être mais c'est des vraies douleurs
donc il faut les soigner ou alors le
médecin c'est pas trop quoi faire parce
que il sait pas ce que c'est auquel cas
faut pas hésiter à aller voir quelqu'un
d'autre une ou un spécialiste genre
urologue par exemple ou quelqu'un qui
est spécialisé dans la douleur je vous
remets le lien dans la description pour
trouver ça près de chez vous voilà DTC
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui et n'hésitez
pas à me suivre sur les réseaux sociaux
pour avoir plus de contenu je vous ai
mis tous les liens dans la description
dites moi dans les commentaires si vous
aimez ce format des testissimo et si
vous voyez passer des topiques
incroyables sur les forums envoyés moi
le lien j'ai racheté un coup d'oeil on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]